[Music]
once Mendel had completed this
monumental study the next big question
for him was well what would happen if
actually I had two traits varying in my
Cross instead of just one trait do they
always go together do they flow through
generations together or can they
actually be independently inherited from
one another so he took a tall plant that
has pink flowers and a short plant that
has white flowers and he made the first
generation hybrid and even at this point
Mendel himself I suspect predicted what
he would see in the first generation
which is the plants would be tall and
they would have pink flowers because
he'd already shown those were the
dominant characters but now the key
became what happens in the next
generation
so he's self fertilized these plants and
then planted the seeds that resulted he
found that nine of them were the
original parental phenotype of tall and
pink three of them were the hybrid
combination of tall and white and three
were the combination of short and pink
and one was the original parental short
and white a 9 to 3 to 3 to 1 ratio and
what that demonstrated to him is that
tall and pink and white and short do not
travel together inevitably but in fact
are behaving as though they are utterly
independent of one another in these
crosses to Mendel this was a very
important second law of inheritance that
he articulated for us
you
[Music]